nouveau numéro de reporter sur france24
direction les balkans et plus exactement
la serbie qui pourrait devenir dans les
années futures le premier producteur
européen de lithium ce métal
indispensables pour fabriquer les
batteries des voitures et dont la
demande mondiale en matière
d'électricité est en pleine croissance
mais l'exploitation de ces nouvelles
ressources implique une extraction
minière qui aura nécessairement des
effets très négatifs sur l'environnement
laurent rouy bonjour vous êtes en duplex
de belgrade en serbie où vous êtes notre
correspondant les écologistes sont très
mobilisés aux côtés des populations
locales il semble avoir gagné la
première manche face au géant minier
international rio tinto qui conduit ce
projet puisque officiellement ce projet
de mine de lithium est à l'arrêt
art effectivement la première ministre
de serbie a déclaré donc il y a quelques
jours que le projet était définitivement
arrêté mais c'est toute la question les
écologistes ne la croit pas et pour une
raison très simple sur le terrain donc à
gornja des élites ça rio tinto continue
ses activités de développement du projet
de la mine et donc les écologistes
soupçonne en fait que
le gouvernement ait simplement cherché à
repousser la décision à l'après
calendrier électoral puisque des
élections arrivent en serbie alors on va
en parler dans un instant on découvre
tout de suite votre reportage serbie la
bataille du lithium reportage signé
laurent
[Musique]
un aller simple pour l'australie c'est
ce que les organisations écologistes
cern souhaite à la multinationale rio
tinto et à son projet de mine de lithium
dans l'ouest du pays pourtant après cinq
mois de protestations le gouvernement a
annoncé l'annulation pure et simple du
projet une déclaration à laquelle les
écologistes ne crois pas
j'aime ans nous demandons une loi
d'interdiction de l'exploitation du bord
et du lithium parce que l'extraction du
lithium n'est pas seulement le problème
de la vallée du hasard mais le risque
d'une catastrophe écologique si on
protège la vallée du ja d'art on protège
toute la serbie la manifestation est
organisée par les ong bouge échange avec
à la tête de l'organisation sa vaut
manojlovic un juriste de 36 ans pour
qu'il faut combattre le projet de mine
de lithium sur le terrain juridique pour
les activistes de bouger change
l'annulation des autorisations de rio
tinto par le gouvernement serait avant
tout une manoeuvre pour mettre en
sourdine un projet impopulaire alors que
des élections générales approche
manojlovic estime que seule une loi
pourrait apporter une garantie
suffisante pour empêcher l'exploitation
du lithium
ce que nous avons obtenu avec les
citoyens est une victoire éclatante un
très grand pas mais je souhaite des
garanties légales nous demandons vingt
ans de moratoire au minimum sur la
prospection et l'exploitation du bord et
du lithium nous n'avons pas confiance en
nos gouvernants qui se sont comportés
comme les représentants de rio tinto et
non pas des citoyens de serbie rien ne
prouve qu'ils tiendront vraiment leur
parole après les élections d'un conte
isbn à l'origine du projet minier la
découverte en 2004 à l'ouest de la
serbie dans la vallée de la rivière ya
d'ar d'un minéral unique au monde layada
rite lapierre contient du lithium en
quantité suffisante pour la production
de batteries de véhicules électriques
mais aussi du bord un composant utilisé
dans l'industrie des détergents la
compagnie anglo-australienne laisse
entrevoir un projet d'une valeur de 2,4
milliards de dollars qui ferait de la
serbie le premier producteur européen de
lithium le village de gornja ned elitsa
et son millier d'habitants se situe au
beau milieu du gisement de yann harry la
sauvegarde de cette région rurale et de
sa nature préservée n'est pas compatible
avec le projet les terres de zlatko
kokanovic fermiers du village seraient
englouties par cette mine dont il
voudrait ne jamais avoir entendu parler
ce jour-là mariana percovich présidente
de l'association contre la mine lui rend
visite
on est des gens ordinaires on s'est
jamais occupé 2002 ni de politique
on est littéralement menacé par une
grande entreprise
tout a commencé en juillet 2020 quand
rio tinto nous expliquer ce qu'il
comptait faire
au début à les écouter tout serait
parfait
la mine aura une superficie que de 20 ou
30 hectares
puis le projet a grandi avec la menace
d'être spoliés de nos terres alors que
les installerait une usine une décharge
c'est là qu'on a commencé à lutter comme
on a pu
vous voyez c'est notre village il est
petit mais moderne il a été construit
par le travail de ses habitants
ici c'est l'école avec environ 240
élèves
ça c'est la poste
l'hôpital
et là c'est rio tinto
le projet minier de rio tinto couvre une
superficie de 600 ha divisé en trois
zones avec un puits de mine descendant à
700 m dans ce périmètre la
multinationale australienne achète
toutes les propriétés qu'elle peut
champs forêts et habitations
ici c'est la zone d'entrée de la mine
ces maisons ont capté les premières
visées par rio
c'est ici que ces rachats problématiques
ont commencé à partir de novembre 2020
regarder de quoi ça a l'air et les toits
ont été démontés les maisons sont en
ruine et ça reste comme ça et ça nous
tournante à chaque fois qu'on les voit
et thoraco story
ça rappelle la guerre les bombardements
tous les malheurs qui sont tombés sur la
tête de ce pays
[Musique]
ce soir-là l'association anti lithium
organise une réunion chez zlatko but
dissuader le plus grand nombre de
villageois de vendre leurs terres une
stratégie qui porte ses fruits malgré
des offres alléchantes
rio tinto peinent à acheter de nouvelles
propriétés dragan le maire du village a
fait le déplacement ses chansons déjà
pollué par les recherches de rio tinto
ce soir là les habitants préparent une
nouvelle action de protestation ils vont
bloquer la frontière avec la bosnie
voisine
on doit y aller
avec le plus de voitures possible mais
aussi avec les femmes et des enfants
c'est tout les valides pour montrer à
quel point nous sommes sérieux et qu'il
n'y aura pas de retour en arrière
même année
[Musique]
direction le champ de dragan en bordure
du village si la mine voit le jour
dragan perdra ses terres et sa maison
mais même sans cela rio tinto a déjà
causé des dégâts sa parcelle
voilà les forages
autour de ces forages il n'y a plus rien
qui pousse même pas l'ambroisie
l'ambroisie pousse sur l'asphalté le
béton mais ici non tous les deux mois
ils viennent échange des tubes rebaine
découvert qu il recouvre une chape de
béton neuf car la concentration
d'arsenic de bord et de je ne sais
quelle autre poison attaque le béton
il change aussi la terre autour du
forage ils font du maquillage robinet il
en a plus de six ans dans les champs
alentours ici ce sont les plus profonds
ils descendent à 700 m
voilà on est dans mon champ là bas le
bouquet d'arbres indique la rivière
corps et nita
et de l'autre côté c'est la rivière ya
d'art
et entre ces deux rivières il prévoit la
décharge 2 km entre les deux ponts de
kilomètres de large 500 mètres vers la
route là bas et 60 mètres de hauteur
c'est une catastrophe totale une
catastrophe annoncée
[Musique]
la protestation est clair à la frontière
serbo bosniaque a mobilisé des habitants
de la région les activistes de toute la
serbie sont venus prêter main forte
la police n'interviendra pas
les manifestants vont ainsi bloqué la
circulation frontalière pendant deux
heures en espérant que leurs
revendications soient prises en compte
le blocage de la frontière a réussi tout
est pour le mieux la manifestation est
pacifique il y a eu des familles avec de
très jeunes enfants et un homme avec sa
femme très malade eux on les a laissé
passer tout de suite ces protestations
révèle une inquiétude à l'échelle du
pays les exemples d'industries
polluantes sont fréquents en serbie avec
à la clé la destruction des écosystèmes
et l'apparition de maladies graves dans
les populations pour la chimiste dragana
djordjevic de l'université de belgrade
c'est la méthode même d'extraction qui
est dangereuse
cette technologie n'a rien inventé par
rapport à la chimie de la fin du 19e ou
début du 20e siècle
on extrait lapierre ont la broye on la
pulvérise on la traite avec des acides
ceux qui rejettent beaucoup de résidus
et de l'eau polluée
l'exploitant prend le minéral qui
l'intéressent et l'export et les déchets
sont laissés sur place à la charge des
populations locales
mais quand ils partiront quand l'âme il
sera fermé les résidus continueront
d'être rincé par la pluie il n'y aura
plus personne pour traiter les eaux de
ruissellement et c'est à ce moment là
qu'il y aura une catastrophe écologique
pour la région alors pour les mouvements
écologistes pas question de baisser la
garde plusieurs projets de mines
similaires seraient en cours dans la
région et la menace pour l'environnement
est palpable
il est nécessaire d'interdire la
recherche et l'exploitation du lithium
et du porte et aux mains c'est notre
dernière revendication et c'est pour
elle ce que nous appelons la population
à manifester demain devant la présidence
et jusqu'à ce que cette revendication
soit acception exact est venu exposer
les adhésions affluent à bouger change
la belgradoise marina pas bleach est une
voie de l'écologie en serbie remarqué
lors d'une campagne sur la pollution de
l'air elle s'oppose à l'exploitation du
lithium
ce sont les paquets pour nos nouveaux
membres certains d'entre eux ont voulu
prendre plus de responsabilités dans
l'association nous aider à recruter
d'autres sympathisants on les a nommé
coordinateur il y en a dans plus de 20
villes de serbie l'annnonce du
gouvernement était nécessaire mais pas
suffisante car tant qu'on met pas un
terme aux activités minières liés au
lithium aucune région de serbie ne se
rassure donc on n'a pas encore gagné on
a fait un pas important mais pas
suffisant
ça vaut tu peux prendre les autocollants
une manifestation de plus se tient à
belgrade mais cette fois avec les
habitants donnaient des guides ça tous
comptent bien profiter de la popularité
du mouvement écologiste pour contraindre
le gouvernement avant les élections
d'avril à inscrire dans la loi
l'interdiction d'exploiter le lithium en
série
rio tinto vient encore d'acheter cette
propriété même avec leur autorisation
annulé ils continuent leur travail ça
montre qu'on ne peut pas faire confiance
ni au gouvernement ni à ses promesses
si rio tinto est expulsé alors cela doit
être inscrit dans la loi sinon il est
possible que rio tinto reviennent que ce
soit dans la vallée du ja d'art ou
quelque part d'autre ce qui est valable
pour rio tinto et pour le ya d'ar doit
être valable pour toute la serbie et
pour n'importe quelle compagnie minière
à s'instaurer compagne
le bras de fer entre le gouvernement et
les tenants d'une serbie propres est
parti pour durer pour les manifestants
tout montre que rio tinto n'a pas
abandonné son projet et que la parole du
gouvernement n'est pas crédible ils se
disent prêts à durcir le mouvement avec
en ligne de mire les élections d'avril
il est trop tôt pour dire qui va
l'emporter
laurent rouy vous avez réalisé ce
reportage on vous retrouve en duplex de
belgrade la serbie at elle les moyens de
dire non à un projet de plus de 2
milliards d'euros
alors il faut faire très attention avec
les chiffres puisque effectivement su
selon rio tinto le projet représenterait
à un investissement une valeur totale de
2 4 milliards de dollars en revanche si
ces chiffres ne sont pas confirmées de
source indépendante
rio tinto parle de 10 % des réserves
mondiales de lithium en serbie mais si
on prend les chiffres officiels par
langue du gouvernement américain il n'y
aurait selon selon les états unis qu 1,8
pour cent des réserves de lithium en
serbie donc il ya une sorte de bataille
des chiffres et il est fort possible que
rio tinto cherche à gonfler la valeur de
son projet en tout cas pour le présenter
sous un jour favorable alors qu'en fait
les quantités les les tonnages avancées
ne semble pas correspondre à ces fameux
10% des réserves de mondial donc il
n'est pas sûr que ce projet et cette
valeur d'autant plus que la région où la
mine serait installé et une région très
agricole qui produit énormément de
produits qui sont exportés par la serbie
des produits laitiers des fruits des
légumes de la viande qui ont aussi une
valeur et qui sont un bassin d'emploi
pour 90 mille personnes qui perdraient
leur emploi si l'abeille venait à voir
le jour alors laurent vous nous le
disions en introduction pour l'instant
le projet est à l'arrêt mais tout va se
jouer lors des prochaines élections en
serbie paraît effectivement donc
l'importance de la pression populaire a
repoussé donc le projet nous sommes dans
un contexte électoral le gouvernement le
président ne sont pas sûrs de repasser
aux élections générales d'avril et donc
on va le découvrir l'évolution de la
position du gouvernement donc dans ces
extraits je n'écoute pas la rue et ne
sert pas les voyous étrangers je sers le
peuple et les citoyens serbes
cette décision concerne notre futur et
je crois que ce serait plus intelligent
et pourront juste qu'elle soit portée
par les élites politiques qui formeront
le nouveau parlement et seront au coeur
du coup comment ces quatre prochaines
années
donc on le voit bien le gouvernement n'a
pas de a beaucoup hésité avant de
prendre de prendre cette décision soit
disant de suspendre le projet de lithium
encore une fois les activités de rio
tinto sur le terrain continue et c'est
la raison pour laquelle les écologistes
n'ont pas confiance en la parole du
gouvernement en tout cas le lithium
s'est invitée dans la campagne
électorale on verra en avril si le
gouvernement s'il est réélu s'il est
reconduit tient sa promesse ou si au
contraire il n'a fait que jouer la
montre pour faire baisser la pression
dans la rue pour revenir de pro b avec
un projet qui est hautement impopulaire
en service laurent rouy correspondant de
france 24 à belgrade merci laurent c'est
la fin de ce magazine merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau mur
sur france info
[Musique]